illegal immigrants could soon be housed
in public schools this summer as New
York city mayor Eric Adams considers
using up to 30 empty schools as
temporary shelters the move comes just
months after protests erupted over the
city's decision to use School gyms as
shelters for illegal immigrants with
critics like our next guest slamming the
city for using School resources to
address Biden's border crisis here to
react New York Congressman Mike Lawler
Congressman good morning glad to have
you on the program morning thanks for
having me so
um these are many in many instances
middle schools across the country four
during the summer I'm sure the argument
being made when they're not occupied by
students but still it just we're using
our school facilities to house illegal
immigrants these are places of learning
they should not be used for housing of
anyone let alone illegal immigrants we
have a crisis in this country created by
the Biden Administration and their
failure to secure our border over 5
million migrants have crossed over
illegally and this Administration is
doing nothing to stop it and Eric Adams
along with New York City's Sanctuary
policies have created a mess they've
taken in over 80 000 migrants since the
spring of last year they have nowhere
else to house them they've been trying
to ship them up into the suburbs into
the Hudson Valley and Long Island and
now they're trying to use schools to
house them we need to secure the Border
we need to increase border patrol we
need to increase the number of Court
Personnel to hear these Asylum cases
expeditiously and New York City needs to
change its Sanctuary City policies
here's what New York City is City Hall
their spokesperson is saying they're
saying well this option is not ideal
none R and we're in no position to take
anything off the table this is just as
you said this is a consequence of of
sanctuary City policies this is nothing
is ideal then why do you have this
policy that creates situations that are
not ideal well that's just it I mean
they had this policy in place and now
they realize they can't handle it well
when you create this situation where
you're willing to accept people are
going to come and people are going to
send folks there and so that is what has
happened and now they're overwhelmed
they're spending upwards of four billion
dollars of taxpayer money including 1
billion from New York state to handle
this crisis the governor and the mayor
have been an absolute disaster they've
failed to coordinate and communicate
with local officials outside of the city
and it has created a Calamity across the
board I want to ask you about your seat
uh former Democratic rep mondare Jones
he's set to launch a bid a comeback bid
for Congress and he's looking to go up
against a Democratic primary opponent
who would eventually end up the winner
of which facing you once Brooklyn now
back to Westchester here's what Montana
Jones's campaign says I've never been
Washington's Choice it's because I stand
up to corruption I battle with
Republicans trying to overthrow our
democracy and ban abortion and even as I
push my party to fight harder for
working people I'm running to finish the
work I began Monda Jones he's back well
he finally found his way back to the
Hudson Valley after running away from
his constituents last year just a year
ago running for congress in Brooklyn he
closed down his office several months
early wouldn't take any constituent
cases the arrogance here is amazing I
mean he thinks he's God's gift to
democracy talking about saving democracy
look he is a radical socialist he
believes in the defund the police
movement he believes in New York's
disastrous cashless bail law he believes
in open borders uh this is a guy who has
a very extreme record of which voters
will certainly know about uh and you
know I've been working in a bipartisan
way I passed my first bill a few weeks
ago with Congressman Richie Torres from
the Bronx uh so we're doing the job
we're representing people and if folks
want to support me they should go to
lawlerforcongress.com or text Monday or
to 85007 okay all right Congressman Mike
Lawler thanks so much for uh joining us
in person this morning on Fox and
Friends appreciate it I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis